[Music]  we thought it'd be chic Kim Kardashian  is going full-throttle with her fashion  I'm driving in Miami and if anyone knows  me they know that I love to drive so I  have a neon weight on not only ji Kim go  all out rockin neon green hair but the  reality star pulled out all the stops  driving a Ferrari to grab dinner at  prime 112 restaurant with her besties  Larsa Pippen and Jonathan Cheban yo  what's the Lambo  the Lambo later Kim's swap cars so that  she could perfectly match her hair with  her bride stepping out of the driver's  seat of a neon Lamborghini to continue  her glam night out her body really is  the accessory Kim had her curbs on  display in a skin-tight silver mini  dress I'm so curvy that if I try to like  put other things on and I look like a  joke and she was serious about keeping  her luscious locks in place with her  hair guru Chris Appleton on hand for  touch-ups but it matches Chris's shirt  [Music]  [Applause]